Dr. Jack Xu is the author of many WebGPU books.
In this course, he will teach you the basics of
WebGPU. Hi, I'm Jack. From this video, you will
learn the basics of WebGPU Graphics Programming.
By building ten separate WebGPU
projects. Each project will be created on top
of the previous one from simple primitives to
complicated 3d graphics. Our end product will be a
beautiful 3D Sinc surface, as shown here. We will
create these WebGPU projects from scratch and
show you how to add 3D graphics with GPU acceleration
to your web applications. Here, I want to thank
Beau and FreeCodeCamp for publishing this
video. FreeCodeCamp is a great resource
for the programming community. And thank you for
all that you do. Before getting into this video,
I'd like to quickly tell you a little bit about
my background. I got my PhD in theoretical physics
and have over 25 years of programming experience
in C, C++, C# .NET and web development. I
have published over 20 books about practical
programming on a variety of topics,
including graphics programming, machine learning,
quantitative finance, numerical
computation methods, and web applications.
Recently, I created a YouTube channel: Practical
programming based on my books. In this channel, I
will present several step by step video series,
in which I will emphasize the usefulness of
example code to real world applications. The first
video series is about WebGPU Graphics Programming
that is based on my recently published book,
"Practical WebGPU Graphics". The projects
presented here are also selected from this book.
My channel: Practical Programming with Dr.
Xu is new and I plan to update it every week.
I would greatly appreciate if you can check
out my channel and subscribe it. Now let's go to
WebGPU Graphics Programming. Now let's start
project one that will set up a development
environment. The source code used in this project
can be downloaded from GitHub link here,
This project uses this specific version. So
now what is WebGPU?  WebGPU is the next generation
graphics API. It is future web standard for
graphics and compute WebGPU will provide
modern 3d graphics and computation
capability with GPU acceleration. In this video,
we will use the following development tools to
build our WebGPU applications. First is the
Visual Studio code, node.js. We use a TypeScript
as our programming language, and we'll use webpack
as our modular bundler. In order to run WebGPU
applications, currently, we have three options.
The first one is to use a Chrome Canary to test
our WebGPU applications. The other option
is to run WebGPU applications on a regular Crome
through origin trial. Starting from Chrome 94, Web
GPU is available as the origin trial in the regular
Chrome. You'll need to register to origin trials
and request the token for your origin. The third
option is that Chome will officially support
WebGPU in May of this year. So after this May,
you will be able to run your WebGPU applications
on regular Chrome. In this video series, I will use
Chrome Canary to test our WebGPU projects. Here, I
suppose you already installed Visual Studio code
node.js, and also installed TypeScript globally
on your machine. Let's start programming. Now
let's open a command prompt window and let's
make a folder make directory gpuapp
and cd into it. And then, we are going to run this command:  npm
init -y to create a package.json file.
Okay, this file will store our dependencies
used in this project. Now, we are going to
install webpack and its command-line interface
using this command: npm install cli. WebPack is
modular bundler that Bundles relevant files
together to generate static assets that can be
used by the web applications. Here we use webpack,
mainly for transpiling TypeScript files, but here
we don't use it to bundle the other types of files,
such as HTML and image files. Now instalation
is complicated. At this point, we are going
to start Visual Studio Code with a command: code
period. Here is Visual Studio Code interface,
you can see we only have a package.json
file, but not much happening here. Now
open a terminal window by pressing Ctrl+J key.
Now, let's install some dependency packages. First,
we will install jQuery and corresponding type
package. npm install jQuery. We will use jQuery
to manipulate the DOM elements in our applications.
Next, we want to install styling CSS and ts
loaders. In case if our project contains
styling sheet file, we need to use style
loader and CSS loader to bundle it. In order to
create TypeScript modules in our project,
We also need to install TypeScript locally. npm
install TypeScript locally. We already installed it
globally before. Now, opening the package.json file. You
can see the script section here only contains the
test attribute, that is not very useful. Here we
are going to replace this section with the code.
Here the code allows you to run WebPack
in different modes like development,
production and watch mode. Now we can see with this
file and close it. Now all the installed packages
are going to be stored in the node_modules
folder. Here the package_lock.json file is
automatically generated for any npm operations.
So we don't need to do anything with it.
Next step is to initialize TypeScript file
with the command tsc --init.
This operation created a configuration file
for TypeScript called the ts_config here.
Now, we open this configuration file
and we need to replace its content
You can see here we set the target to the es6
also note we define the root directory as src
and output the directory as dist, distribution
folder. Now save this file and close it.
We then create some folder structures for
our project. First, let's create the src folder.
So here we create a folder called src. We will
store all the source files in this folder. Next,
we create a dist folder, which will contain all
files that will be uploaded to the web server for
running our applications. In this folder, there
is at least one HTML file. let's add an index
html file to this folder. Add another file index.html,
and add some code to it. You can see here we add
the title WebGPU project. Here h1 title check
whether your browser supports WebGPU
or not. We also have h2 DOM elements here
and set its id equal to id_gpu_check. This
h2 element will be used to display text string
that will be returned by a typescript function
which will be created later. Now we are about
to finish the development environment
setup, but we have missed a key step, that is,  we
need to install the WebGPU package. WebGPU
working group has created a type definition
for WebGPU standard. This package matches the
work-in-progress WebGPU API, which is currently
not very stable. So it can change
almost weekly. So be careful to use it. Anyway,
let's go ahead to install it with this command.
So here we specify the version 0.1.12,
this is the latest version, we install it
called  webgpu types. Because the WebGPU is not
backward compatible, so you better use the same
version to run our project. Otherwise, you
need to do some modification to your code
to run application. So I suggest you use the
same version here 0.1.12. After
installation we need to configure it.
Open TypeScript configuration file.
You can see here we already configured it. We add
WebGPU types and node in the types section here
you can see here we have node type. So we
need to install it use this command to install
this node type. Okay, the WebGPU is now available
for our project. Now let's add some TypeScript
file to our project. First, added a new file
called helper.ts file to the src folder. So
we added a new file called helper.ts file and
add some code to it. You can see here we use
this navigator.gpu variable to check the GPU
availability. This variable is defined in the web
GPU API. So you can see here we use the fat arrow
to define the typescript function. Next, we
need to create an entry point file called main.ts
file. Okay, save this file first. And close it.
Let's add another new file to the src folder
called the main.ts file. Now add some code
to this file, we just import the jQuery and
also import the checkWebGPU function from helper.ts
file, just implemented. So here we
define id_gpu_check to display the string returned
by the checkWebGPU function. Here the id represents
h2 DOM element defined in the index.html file,
make sure this ID is the same as ID defined
in that file. Next, we also need to
create a webpack configuration file. Now add
a new file to the root directory webpack_config.js file.
You can see here we define a bundle output
directory as dist and an entry point is named
main here. The main, src main.ts File. Note that
the output file has always with bundle.js
extension. Now we can save this file and
close it. Now we can run the following command
from terminal window to bundle our TypeScript
file: npm run prod in the production mode
Okay finished. You can check the bundle file in the
dist folder. You can see here we have several
main bundle.js files. This is our bundle file,
this is license file, this is source map file. This
main.bundle.js file has been
referred in the index.html file. You can
see here, this is the main.bundle.js This bundle
file is generated by webpack. In order to test
our application we also need a server. Here we will
use live server extension. Click on the extension link
search for live server. This
first one is live server. Here I already
installed it. Otherwise we have install
link here. If you haven't installed it, just click
install button to install the live server. So
I suppose you already installed it. Now we can open
index.html file, right click anywhere open
with live server, click this link. This will
open our default browser to display the web page.
Unfortunately, if your default browser is regular
Chrome, it will displays the message: your current
browser does not support WebGPU. So in order
to run WebGPU applications here we will install
Chrome Canary. So here search for Chrome Canary.
Click it. So this nightly build for developer. Just
download Chrome Canary and install it.
I already installed this chrome Canary on my
machine. Please remember the location where
your Chrome Canary is installed. Okay, I suppose
you already installed it. Let's go back to Visual
Studio Code. We want to change the default
browser to a Chrome Canary, which will be easy to test
our WebGPU applications. So press Ctrl+Shift+P and
type the preference opening setting here. So
open this file. Here, you need to add these
three lines here. live server setting don't so
info message. I set it to true, this doesn't
matter. I also set the root directory as dist
because our index.html file is in this directory.
So this the ones custom browser command
line here defines the default browser. So you
need to replace this code. So you need to copy
your Chrome Canary exe file location and paste it
here, you must change it to match your situation.
Now we can save this file and close it. Now
start the Chrome Canary and type Chrome
flags and search for WebGPU. Here,
enable it here I already enabled it.
If you're not, you just need to enable it to make
WebGPU available for our Chrome Canary. Okay,
we can close it. Okay finally we can test our
development environment for WebGPU applications.
Here we have a link on the status bar area you can
see go live link. This time it will start Chrome
Canary browser. Click this link. You can see
Greate your current browser supports WebGPU,
Congratulations, we have successfully set up the
development environment for WebGPU applications.
Now we completed our first WebGPU project that
shows how to set up development environment.
This is project 2 of this video series.
Here I will explain how to create a colorful
triangle in WebGPU as shown here. This
is a colorful triangle. This project is based
on our first project. You can open project one
directly from Visual Studio Code or clone the
source code from the GitHub repository. git clone.
This is a GitHub link for the project one
source code. I also put this project 2 source
code into the GitHub repository. Here is the link.
So you can download the source code used in
this project from this link. Now we will open the
project one directly from Visual Studio Code. Here
we first add a CSS file called the site.css to the
src folder, src folder, add a new file called
site.css. Type some code into this file
then save and close it. Just like WebGL,
The first thing we need to do to use WebGPU
for graphics rendering is to create a canvas element.
From the dist folder, open
index.html file. Here we need
to change h2 elements from here.
Here we define canvas element
with ID canvas-webgpu. Later we will
create WebGPU Graphics on this canvas.
The WebGPU programming consists of two parts
one is the control code written in typescript
or javascript, and the other part is shader code
run on the GPU. Here we will use the official shader
language for WebGPU called WGSL, which is short
for WebGPU Shading Language. To take advantage
of the code highlight in VS Code, we will
convert the shader code with wgsl
extension into typescript-like module.
To do this, we need to install a shader loader
for webpack. Now open a new terminal window.
Run the following command to install the shader
loader called npm install ts-shader-loader
This loader was originally created for loading
GLSL shader code. But we will make it works
for WGSL here. Next, open WebPack
configuration.js file and add the following
code to it. Here the file with wgsl, glsl, vs,
vs means vertex shader, fs, fs means
fragment shader. So the file with these extensions
will be treated as a shader code by this
shader loader. We then need to install
WGSL extension from VS Code. Click this
extension link, search for WGSL. Here
is first one: wgsL provides syntax highlight
I already installed this module. So you can see
here the code highlight. In this case, it is easy
to write shader code using this extension. So if you
haven't installed it, so click this install button
to install it. Next we need to add some type
declarations for our shader. Add a new sub folder
to the src folder. A new folder called types. Then
add a new file called shader.d.ts file. Inside this
file we add some contents to this file. Here we
declare module. The file with wgsl, glsl, vs or fs
we declare this file as module. So right now we
can save this file and close it. Now we can
write our shader code. In the src folder add a new
file called a shader.wgsl file. Then add some code
From this code, you can see that there are two
shaders here. One is vertext shader and another
is fragment shader. We have shader function for
vertex called vs_main function. vs means
vertex shader function. Here we have fs
main: fragment shader main function.
The vertex shader takes vertex data including
word position, color, and texture as the input the
output is the position in the clip coordinates. While
the other outputs such as color and texture
will be passed to the fragment shader. These
values will then be interpolated over the
fragments to produce a smooth color gradient. Now
back to our example. In the vertex shader, we first
define the output structure here, that contains
built-in position and the output color
called  vColor. Inside the vs_main function, we first
define three vertices of our triangle using the
floating point vec2 vector. So we have
three vertices. We also specify a colors for each
vertex using a floating point vec3 vector.
You can see the first one is 1 0 0. This means
red. The second color is 0, 1, 0 the
green, the final one is 0, 0, 1, which is a blue. So we define
different color for each vortex. Next, we
define output using the output structure here
we thenconvert 2D vector of the position
into a vec4, the four dimensional vector
we put a z component at zero and a w
component as one. Similarly we convert
3d vector for the color into vec4 here. The
one represents transparency of the color
In the fragment shader, we take the output
color from the vertex shader as an input and
return it as the fragment color. Okay,
this is the shader we will use when
creating our colorful triangle in WebGPU.
Now we can save this file and close it.
Next, we'll use TypeScript to write WebGPU
control code. Open the main.ts file.
And replace is content with the following new
code. Here we first introduce the checkWebGPU
function from helper.js File. Then, from shader.wgsl
file, we introduce our shader from this file,
we also import the site.css file.
Here we will use it to configure our web
page layout. Next, we create a new function called
Create triangle. This function must be async, you can
see async function because WebGPU API itself is
async. Inside this function we first check
whether your browser supports WebGPU or not.
In WebGPU, we can access the GPU by calling the
request adapter here. Once we have this adapter
we can call request device method to get
GPU device. This device provides a context to work
with the hardware. And an interface to create
GPU objects, such as buffer and texture.
We can also run commands on this GPU device
As with WebGL, we need a context for our canvas
element that will be used to display graphics.
Here we use the canvas element to request web
GPU context. You can see here get content by
the name webgpu. This is a keyword used by WebGPU
to create context. We then configure this context
with the device and the format. Next, we define
the render pipeline by calling the Create render
pipeline method. Inside this pipeline we
have several attributes. The first one is a vertex,
where we'll assign the shader to the module. Here
with an entry point as the vs_main function
this function is created in our shader file.
Similarly for the fragment attribute we
assign the shader to the module an entry point as
fs_main function. The another required attribute
is a primitive here, this attribute
contains a field called the topology. We set it to
triangle-list because we want to create a triangle
in this project. Next we create the command encoder
and render pass by calling the beginning
render pass. This render pass accepts a
parameter of the type GPU render pass descriptor
as the render pass option. Here we only use color
attachments that is used to store image information.
In our example, it stores the background color
in the clearValue area we have another field called
the loadValue. This field will be removed from
WebGPU in next version, so we don't use it here.
Next, we'll assign the pipeline to our render
pass and draw our triangle by calling the
draw method here. we call the end function
to finish current render pass, meaning
that no more instructions are sent to the GPU.
Finally, we submit all instructions to the queue
of the GPU device for execution. After running the
command, our triangle will be written to the GPU
context and displayed on our canvas element. Now we
finished the implementation of our create triangle
method. This method provides basic procedure
to create WebGPU applications, that is, first we
initialize WebGPU API, create shader program,
set up render pipeline and build render pass,
call draw function, submit instructions to the GPU
for execution. Finally, we call the Create
triangle function to generate our triangle.
Up to now we have finished our programming for
this project. We can now run the following command
on the terminal window: npm run prod to
bundle our typescript code in production model.
Okay finished. Our Bundle file is created
successfully. Now we can click the go-live link
from here to open Chrome Canary to
view our triangle. Click this link.
Here is our colorful triangle. You can see here is red,
green and blue. From one vertex to another you
can see the color changes smoothly because
WebGPU interpolates the color internally
which gives a smooth color gradient.
Now we have completed project 2.
This is a project three: we will create a colorful
square using GPU buffer. In the last project,
we create a colorful triangle in WebGPU by writing
the vertex and color data directly in the shader
code. This approach is only possible for creating
very simple shapes. It is almost impossible to use
this direct approach for creating complex 3d
graphics with different colors and textures.
In this project, I will introduce GPU
buffer and show you how to use it to store vertex
and color information. In this example, we
will create a colorful square to explain
the concept of the GPU buffer. Here we will
introduce several new concepts that
will be the foundation to create complex
3d graphics objects. GPU buffer in Web
GPU represents a block of memory that can be used
to store data for GPU operations. In this project,
I will show you how to use the GPU buffer to
store vertex position and color data. You can
download the source code used in this project
from this GitHub repository link. You
can see we have specific commitment
version, this version is specific for our current
project. Now let's start Visual Studio Code and
open project 2 that we built in the last video.
Okay, here's the project 2 we used in the last
video. Now let's first make some changes to
the index,html file. From the dist folder,
open index.html file. Now we need to change
here the h1 title to Create Square Using GPU
Buffer. So we don't need to change the other part
of the code. So we can save this file. Next from the
src folder, open the helper.ts file. Now we need to
add a new function called the InitGPU to this
helper file. So we need to add some code here.
You can see we place all WebGPU initialization
code to this function, initGPU. So this can
avoid code duplication because initialization
will be same for all WebGPU projects. This
function is an async function, and it returns
the device, canvas, format, and context,
which will be used when we create a render pipeline
and render pass. We also want to add another
function called Create GPU buffer to this helper
file. So we need to add another function here
called Create GPU buffer. You can see this
function takes three inputs: the device, the data,
and the usage flag. Here we set the default
usage flag to vertex or copy destination.
Here you can see we call the device create
buffer method to create a GPU buffer
and a set the size as the data the byte length to
allocate the room for the buffer data. The other
attribute here mapped at creation, we set this
attribute to true. This means that the GPU buffer
is owned by CPU, which is accessible in Read
Write from typescript code. Once the GPU buffer
is mapped, the application can ask for access to
range of content with get, for example, here
get mapped range method and set it to
the data to be stored in the buffer. Pleace note
the mapped GPU buffer cannot be directly used by the
GPU and it must be unmaped by calling the upmap
method. Here, our create GPU buffer method
returns unmapped buffer, which can be used
by the GPU. So be careful here about the GPU
buffer mapped and unmapped states. Now we
can save this file and close it. Next
we need to make changes to the main.ts file
from src folder open the main.ts file. We
need to replace is content with the new code.
You can see here we first introduce
initGPU and create GPU buffer
from helper.ts file and then we introduce
the shader. The shader code will be discussed
in a moment. Inside the Create square method, we first
call the initGPU method to create a GPU
object and then get the device from it. Next, we
define the vertex data and the color data here.
You can see this is our vertex data, color data.
Here is vertex coordinates of our square a, b, c, d.
so, the coordinates like here a minus point
five minus one and this is a, b, d, we have
divide this square into two triangles a, b, d, d, b, c,
the vertices of each triangle must be arranged
in the counter-clockwise order. You can see
here a-b-d, d-b-c. We also assign a color
to each vertex. You can see a red b green c blue
and d yellow. You can see here it for a is red for
B is green, and so so. These data are consistent
with the coordinates, shown in this figure. Of course,
you can also divide the two triangle in other way
around. For example, a-b-c, c-d-a. So you draw
the diagonal this way. So get another two triangles.
This doesn't metter. Next, we create a two buffers
by calling the Creator GPU buffer: one
is the vertex buffer and another is color buffer. Next,
we create a pipeline by calling the Create render
pipeline method. The new code we add here is for
the buffer attribute. Before we don't have this
buffer attribute. Now, it is a two element array,
the first element is for the vertex position.
The second is for the color. You can see for
the vertex position we have arrayStride
we set it to eight since each vertex
is represented using two floating 32 elements.
Each floating 32 number requires four bytes while
for the color it is represented for each vertex
using three floating 32 elements. So, its array
stride is set to 12. The another important
parameter here is shader location. For the vertex
position we set the shader location to zero, and
for the color we set the shader location to one
The other part of the code is very similar to that
used in the previous project. Here we set the
primitive topology to the triangle list. One
new thing here is that after setting the pipeline
to the render pass here, we also need to set
the vertex buffer to the render pass using vertex
buffer and color buffer. You can see here we set vertex
buffer as zero slop is vertex buffer. And
at slot one, we set the color buffer. In the draw
function here, we set the number of vertices
to six because we have two triangles now.
Now we finished the modification to this file.
Now we can save this file. Next we need
to make modifications to our shader code.
from the src folder, open shader.wgsl file. Here
we need to replace his context with new code.
Here you can see we didn't define any vertices
and colors in this shader code because we store
these data in GPU buffer. Instead we introduce
two inputs one is at location zero pos, and
other is the color at location one, which must be
consistent with the shader location definition in the
pipeline in our main.ts file, because
we define the shader location as zero you can
remember for the position and the shader location
is one for the color. So here position is zero.
And here color location is one. This is how we set up
the relationship between the vertex shader and the
GPU buffers. Note we define them here as a vec4
f32.  For the color same thing vec4 f32.
They look like they are not very consistent
with the data stored in the vertex and color
buffers where the for the position, it is a 2d array
and for the color, it is 3d array. This is because
WGSL shader is smart enough to automatically
convert them into  vec4 types by adding
zero to the z component and one for the w
component. You can see here we also define
two outputs one is position, one is vColor using a
structure. Inside this vs_main function, we
process the position and color data by assigning
the pos to the position and a color to the V
color. Inside the fragment shader we introduce
the vColor from the vertex shader and return
as fragment color. Okay, this is the shader we
will use when creating our square. We can now save
this file and close it. Now we can run the
following command in the terminal window to bundle
our typescript code: npm run prod
to bundle our code in production mode. Okay,
the bundle file is created successfully.
Now we can click the Go Live link
to open Chrome Canary to view our square. So click
this go live link. Here is our colorful square
with different vertex color. Here is red,
green, blue and yellow. From one vertex to another
you can see the color changes smoothly because
WebGPU interpolates color internally
which gives a smooth color gradient. Okay,
now we finished the project three.
In projects two and three, I demonstrated how
to create a triangle and a square graphics in
WebGPU applications. In fact, this two objects
are flat and two dimensional. We have not created
any real 3d graphics yet. In this project 4, I will explain
how to create a 3d cube with distinct
face colors. This is the first real 3d object we
are going to create in a WebGPU application. You
can download the source code used in this project
from this GitHub repository link. Here we have
specific version for this project.
This example involves a lot of code and
mathematics. So please get ready to digest it. In
order to create a real 3d objects in WebGPU,
you need to have the math background of 3d
matrices and transformations. Since our computer
screen is a two dimensional, it cannot directly
display 3d Objects. To view 3d objects on a 2d
screen, you have to project your object from
2d to 3d, that will involve a series of coordinate
transformations. From here you can see that we
define 3d object in the object coordinate system
here. We then perform various transformations on
the object, including scaling, translation and
rotation. We call this transformation as a model
transform. After this transformation, we convert
an object in the object coordinates into
the object in the world space. Next, the view
transformation locates the viewer in World space
and transform our 3d object into camera space
that also called the eye coordinates. The purpose
of the projection transform here is to define a view
volume called  view frustum, right here.
This is a view frustum. This is used in two
ways: it determines how an object is a project
on the screen. It also defines which portions
of the object are clipped out of the final image.
That is only the portion inside this frustum
will be kept and anything outside of this frustum
will be clipped out. Finally, we use the view
port transform to convert the clip coordinates
into the normalized device coordinates. In WebGPU.
The viewport transform here is automatically
performed in the shader code. Please note
that like a WebGL, the WebGPU API
does not provide any functions for
working with transformation. In this project, we
will use a JavaScript package called GL matrix to
create 3d matrix operations and transformations.
Since the 3d matrix and transformations are common
for any computer graphics programming, here, I
suppose you already have this math background,
I will not spend any more time on this. Instead,
I will concentrate on how to create 3d objecta
in WebGPU applications. From this project, you
will learn somehow important concepts in web
GPU that is uniform buffer and binding group.
We will use a uniform buffer to represent
the transformation and projection matrices,
and then use the binding group to pass
the uniform buffers to the vertex shader. Now
we start with our Visual Studio Code
and open our project three that we built
in the last section. Here is code we used in
project three. First we need to install a new
NPM package called GL matrix: npm install gl
matrix. We will use this package to perform
matrix operations and 3d transformations
Now let's make some changes to the index
dot HTML file. From the dist folder, open
index dot HTML file. Here we need to
change the h1 title to Cube with Distinct
face Color. So we don't need to change other
parts of the code. Save this file.
Here we are going to create our 3d cube.
these are the coordinates our cube. From this
diagram you can see there are eight vertices and
six faces. if we each face has a different color
each vertex will then have three different
colors. For these vertices, For example, c
we have the top face, front face, and the right
face. Because different face a different
color. So the vertex C can have three different
colors depending on which face we talk about
Here is the front face A, B C D. You can see A B C
D here. As we did before, we can now
divide this front face into two triangles. One
is  A-B-C, C-D-A, two triangles you can see here
ABC and CBA. In this way, you can perform triangulization
for the other faces. Next add a new TypeScript
file to the src folder and add a new file vertex
_data.ts file. Add the new code to this file
Here is the positionn data for our cube:
this is front face, right face, and six faces
This is the color data for the different faces. You
can see front face we use blue color, right face
is red, and back face is yellow and so on.
So different face has a different color. All the
position coordinates uand the color are
consistent with this diagram shown here. Now we can
seave this file and close it. Next we will make
some changes to the shaderr code. From src folder
open shader.wgsl file. Now we
need to replace this content with the new code
You can see this shader is different from that
we used in project three because we need to
incorporate the uniform buffers that store
transformation and projection matrices
Here we define a uniform structure and
then use the binding group to pass the
model-view-projection matrix to the shader. Here
the mvp matrix means model view projection matrix
You can see here the variable type is uniform.
Next we define the output structure
as we did in the last project.  We define position
and vColor. This is the same as before. For
the vs_main function we also define the two inputs:
one is the position one is the color, the same as
the last project. And inside this function only
difference is the position not only has the pos
here but we also multiply by this model view
projection matrix. So perform the transformation
on this position. For the fragment shader, we still
use vColor as input and return it as
fragment color. This is the same as in the project
three. Now we can save this file and close it
Now we open the helper.ts file from
src folder. Here we first need to import from
gl-matrix. We need to introduce the vector
three, mat4, and then add a new method
called Create View projection to this
file. This method create view projection takes
four input arguments: first is the aspect
ratio, the camera position, camera look at
direction, and the camera up direction. Here
we first create a view projection and
view projection matrices. We then use
a mat4.perspective and mat4.lookAt
to create projection and view matrices. Next
we use mat4.multiply method to combining
projection matrix with view matrix to form
our view projection matrix. This function
returns the view matrix, projection matrix, and view
projection, and the camera option. The camera option
will be used in the next project when we discuss
the camera control. Now, we need to add another
function called the create transformation, which
is used to construct the model matrix
Here we first create three rotation
matrices for rotation about X Y and Z axes
We then create a translation and scaling matrices.
Next we perform individual transformation
for the input arguments here. Finally
we combine all transformations together to
form our final transform matrices which is our
model matrices. Now save this file and close it
Next we need to make some changes to the
main.ts file. From the src folder open main.ts file.
Here we need to replace is content with the
new code. Here we first introduce some methods
from a helper.ts file, including the
newly created createTransforms, create view
projection, we alsointroduce the cube data
from the vertex_data.js file, as well as mat4
from the gl-matrix library. Inside this create3d
object method, the code is very similar to that
we used in the project three. Here, we create the
vertex buffer, you can see and the color buffer
using a cube data positions and cube data colors.
Here is pipeline code. Also similar to the
project three. The difference here is array
stride for the position is 12 instead of
eight. Right now for our cube, we have x,
y, z coordinates. So we have 12 here
For our color, still 12 Because we have RGB
elements. Here, we also set the shader location to zero
for the position and the shader location is one for
the color. The only difference in the pipeline
here is we add this depth_stencil attribute.
Here we set depthWriteEnabled to true to enable
the deoth stencil testing. The depth-stencil
testing determines whether or not a giving pixel
should be drawn. For 3d graphics. enabling
depth stencil testing is very important. Otherwise,
you may get unexpected results. The
following code is new and specific to our 3d cube.
Here we create a model view and a model view
projection matrices by calling the CREATE
VIEW projection method. We then create a uniform
buffer for our mvp matrices. You can see here
the usage, we set it as a uniform for our
transformation. The size is 64 since
our matrix is four by four, so we have 16
elements. Each element is a floating 32 number,
so its size is 64. We then define
the binding group by calling Create Binding group
for this uniform buffer. Here we set the layout
as a default pipeline get binding group layout
zero. This means we use the binding group
zero layout. In the entries attribute, we set
the bindings to zero and set buffer here
to the uniform buffer we just defined here.
If we have a more uniform buffers, we can add the
elements here. Put them into this entries array. In
addition to the texture view from a context we
also introduce the depth texture. Here we set
the size as our canvas width and height. And
the format that we use here is depth 24 Plus, you
can also use other format. The usage here we set it to
render_attachment. Now our render pass description,
includes two parts: one is  the color attachments
and other part is teh depth stencil attachment.
The color attachments is the same as we use in
the project three. The depth stencil attachment is
specific for our 3d Cube. Next, we construct the
model matrix by calling create transforms method
defined in the helper.ts file. We then obtain
Model View MVP matrix by multiplying the
model matrix with the view projection matrix.
So we got a final model view projection matrix
and then we add this model view projection matrix
to our uniform buffer by calling the write buffer
method. You should already be familiar
with the following code here. We just
define render pass and a set vertex color buffer.
But we also need to set the binding group here using
uniform binding group which is needed to
pass the uniform buffer to the vertex shader. Now,
we finished the modification to the
main.ts file. We can then save this file.
Up to now we have finished all programming for
this project. Then we can run the following
command in the terminal window to bundle
our code in production mode: npm run prod.
Okay, the bundle file is created successfully.
Now we can click the Go Live link to open
Chrome Canary to view our 3d Cube. Click
this link. Here is our cube with distinct
Face Color displayed on this page. Okay
we have finished this project.
This is project 5, in which we will discuss
the animation and camera control. In the last
project, I explained how to use the uniform
buffer to create a 3d cube. In this project,
I already illustrate how to animate that cube
and how to use mouse to interact with the cube,
you can download the source code used in this
project from this GitHub repository link
Here the specific commit version is used
for this project. For animation we will use
the JavaScript requestAnimationFrame function.
This function can make changes to your screen
in an efficient and optimized manner. Here
is an example of using request animation frame.
You can see here we loop over and over again using
a recursion. Here we first define the DOM element
in the UI and define a start number of zero
here. Next, we create a count function that
increases number by one. And then set it as
a text content for the counter element. Inside
this counter function we call request animation
frame and pass the counter function itself as
a callback function. This causes it to run
again just before the next frame. Finally,
we use the request animation frame function
to start the animation. This is a basic usage
of the request animation frame. For using the mouse
to interact with cube, we will use the npm package
called the 3d view controls. This package can be
used to control the camera with your mouse you can
then interact with 3d object by controlling the
camera. Now let's start Visual Studio Code and open
project four that we built in the last section.
Here is the code used in project four.
First we need to install JavaScript
package called 3d view controls. Open
terminal window and run
npm install 3d view controls
We will use this package for camera
control. The package is already installed. Now
let's make some changes to index dot HTML file.
From the dist folder, open this file. First
we need to change h1 title to Animation and Camera
control. We also need to add two
radio buttons that let you select whether
you want animation or camera control here
You can see the radio button. Okay now we can save this
file. The shader code in this example is the
same as that used in the project 4. So
we don't need to make any change to the shader
code. Now from the src folder, open helper.ts
file. Here we need to add a new method called
Create Animation. We need to add create_animation
here. This is code for create animation.
method. Here the draw augments is a callback
function. Here we want to animate the rotation
around X, Y and Z axes using the step function
here, the step function. The Create Animation has a
boolean argument here is_animation that
controls whether you want to animate the object
or not. Now we can save this file and close it.
Next we need to make some changes to the main.ts
file. Open main.ts file. We need to
replace the content with the your code.
This code actually is very similar
to the code used in the last project. Here,
in addition to the other function introduced from
helper.ts file, we also introduce Create Animation
functionwe just created. Note that we use here
require to introduce 3d view controls
module, instead of the import. This is because
the 3d view controls package was created using
old modules approach. So we have to use require
instead of import here. Here we define
create camera from this package. In the create 3d
object method, we introduce an input argument
is_animation, and we set its default value to
true here. Here is the initialization code and
pipeline code are the same as those used in the
last project, we don't need to make any change to
this code. In the creating a uniform data section
we define v-matrix, this  is view matrix
is a new matrix. Next, we need to add rotation and
camera. Rotation we define using vec3 and
camera we define create-camera here.
we have arguments canvas and camera option,
we don't need to make any changes to the code
for creating a uniform buffer here and a uniform
binding group. This is render pass description is
also the same as that used in the last project,
here, we put this render pass related code inside
the new function called draw function. This
draw function is defined as a callback
function for our animation. You can see here
if is_animation is not true we use
the camera to generate our view matrix.
And then multiply projection matrix with this view
matrix to form our view projection matrix. The
rest code of the draw method is the same as that
we used in the last of the project. Here we start
animation by calling the Create Animation
function. You can see we have callback function,
using the draw function defined here. Finally,
we need to add a radio button selection here,
you can see that if the radio checked value is
equal to animation, we run animation. Otherwise,
we use the camera control. Now we finished
the modification to the main.ts file. So we can
save this file now. Up to now we have finished
the all programming. Now we can run the following
command in the terminal window: npm run prod
to bundle our TypeScript code.
Okay, the bundle file is created successfully.
Now we can click the Go Live link to open Chrome
Canary to view our 3d Cube. Click this
go live link. You can see the animated
cube on this page. It rotates continuously because
we call the animation mode. Now you can click
on this camera control radio button here,
then you can use the left mouse button
to rotate the cube and the use right button
to move it around. And you can also use mouse
wheel to zoom in, zoom out the cube. So
you can use the mouse to interact with the cube.
So now with how completed this
project. In the previous several projects,
I explained how to create some 2d and 3d objects.
However, when rendering these graphics objects with
solid colors, you may find that the image
looks flat and it is failed to illustrate
the 3d nature of the objects. This is because we
neglect interaction between light and surface in
our objects. Lighting helps provide visual effect to
a scene so that it looks more realistic. Lighting
is one of the most important factors for creating
real world shaded 3d graphics objects. However,
WebGPU does not provide much built-in
features on lighting. It just runs two functions:
vertex and fragment shaders. If you want the
lighting effect in your 3d scene, you have
to create the lighting model yourself. In this
project, I will build a simple lighting model in
WebGPU and use it to simulate the light source.
Here you can download the source code used in this
project from this GitHub repository link. Here
The specific commit version is used
for this project. Here I will discuss three
types of light sources, ambient light,
diffuse light, and specular light. The
ambient light is the light that illuminates
all objects uniformly regardless of their location
or orientation. It is a global illumination
in an environment. The diffuse light and
specular light reflection depends on the angle
of the light to a surface. When the light hits
the surface., the diffuse reflection occurs in
all directions, as shown here, while the specular
light reflection occurs in a single direction.
as shown here. Here shows the light reflection on a
torus surface. On the left here, light is only from
ambient light, you can see this torus looks very
flat. Here in the center shows light from both
ambient plus the diffuse light. You can see
the 3d feature already shows here. On the right here,
we have three light sources: ambient plus diffuse
and plus specular lights. You can see this
torus looks more realistic. So, this is the
light model we want to build in this project.
The light reflection depends on the angle at which
the light hits the surface. The angle is essential
to the diffuse light and the specular light.
This angle is always associated with surface
normal that is a perpendicular to the surface.
To build the light model, we need to calculate the
surface normal based on the direction in which
the surface is facing. Since the surface of 3d
object can be curved, it can face different
directions at different vertex. So,
a normal vector is usually different for different
vertex that is normal vector is always associated
with a particular point on the surface. Here shows
normal vector for 3d cube. Here, the front face is
pointing towards the screen. So its normal
vector is 001. The right face is facing
direction to the right. So its normal is 1
00. And the top face is facing towards the top. So,
its normal vector is 010. So, similarly, you
can specify the normal vectors for the back
left and the bottom faces. Note that the
length of the normal vectors should be always
one, that is, we need to normalize the
normal vectors. For a general quadrilateral A B
C, D, its 4 vertices may not in the same plane,
we can divide it into two triangles, A, B,
C and C D A. We can calculate its surface
normal in two steps. First, we calculate the
weighted normal for each triangle, which is a
weighted by the area of that triangle.
The triangle with larger area will get
more weight. As we know the area of a triangle
is proportional to its cross product of two
sides. For example, here, for triangle A, B,
C, we have a cross product B, C, and C-A,
b c and a c. Similarly for the triangle C
D A, we have a cross product D A and A C. The next
step is to calculate the surface normal from the
weighted triangle normals, that is, the surface
normal equals the sum of two weighted normals,
and we can then normalize it. So we get this
quadrilateral normal equals normalize this
two cross products. The sum of this one triangle
plus another one. So, we can combine these two
terms to form one term equals cross product of
C A and D B. So, this means the surface normal
for this general quadrilateral just equals
to the cross product of C, A, and d b. Just
equal to the cross product of these two diagonal
vectors. We will use this formula to calculate
the light model for our 3d surfaces. Once we
have calculated the normal vector, we can use it
to compute the light intensity. For diffuse light,
its intensity is proportional to the cosine
between the light vector here and a normal
vector N. You can see here the cosine alpha equals
normalized L dot N here. If we define the Id, the
diffuse intensity, Kd the diffuse material
property, so we can have this formula: the diffuse
intensity equals Kd times maximum cosine alpha and 0. Here
the maximum is used to avoid the negative value of
the cosine alpha here, we only take the positive
value. We can also add the ambient light to
the diffuse light intensity like this. Here Ia
is ambient light intensity. So the total light intensity
is maxima Kd and here is the Ia. So we add
the ambient intensity to this diffuse light like
this. For specular light, we have two models
one is Phong model, this model is very simple. So
the Is, the intensity of the specular light, equals
to Ks, Ks is speclar material property, and s
is the shininess of the surface or roughness,
the V is the view direction, R is reflection
direction. One issue with Phong model is that
the angle between the view direction and reflection
direction has to be less than 90 degrees in order
for the specular Phong term to contribute. We can
use the Blinn-Phong model to address this issue.
Blinn-Phong model uses a different set of
vectors for its computation, based on the half
angle vector. Here's a half angle vector, you can see L
is the light direction, N is normal vector, V is
view direction, H is the half angle vector defined
L is the light direction plus the view direction. The
view direction plus the light direction gives H
here. The formula in Blinn-Phong model becomes
N dot H instead of V dot R here. So the
angle between this N and H is always less
than 90 degrees. So this N dot H
always gives positive value. So we will use this
Blinn-Phong mode in our calculation for the specular
light. Now let's go to the programming part.
We started with Visual Studio Code and open
project five that we built in the last section.
Here is the code for our project file. Now let's
implement the light model in the shader code. From
src folder open the shader.wgsl. We need
to replace its content with the new code.
Here we first define the uniform structure
here that contains view-projection matrix,
the model matrix and normal matrix. Here
the normal matrix is transformation matrix
for the normal vector data. When applying a transform
to a surface, we need to derive the normal vector
for the resulting surface from original normal
vectors. In order to transform the normal vector
correctly, we don't simply multiply them by the
same matrix used to transform our object, but we
need to multiply them by the transpose of the
inverse of that matrix. Since the current WG
SL version does not implement the matrix inverse
function yet, so we have to make this transpose
of the inverse of the transform matrix in
TypeScript code, and then pass it as a uniform
matrix as shown here, normal matrix. We then
define output structure that contains three
variables: built-in position, the v-position
the position after some transformation, we call it the
v-position and the v_normal, which is a normal
vector after transformation. In our vs
main function, it contains two input arguments
one is vertex position called the pos and
one is normal vecctor data. Inside this function, we only
perform the model transform on the position. This gives us
v-position here because it is used in the light
calculation. The  v-normal is a result of normal
vector data multiplied by the normal transform
matrix here. And the default position here
is obtained by performing model-view and projection
transform on the vertex data. For the fragment shader
we first introduce the uniform
structure called FragUniform that contains two
variables: one is light position of light
vector, and the other one is eye position. Or
view vector. It also has another structure called
LightUniform. Here contains parameters for our
light model. Here's a light color and a specular
color. The specular light can have its own
color, and the other parameters contain ambient
intensity, diffuse intensity, specular intensity
and the specular shininess. Here the fs_main
function takes v_position and v_normal
as inputs. Inside this function, we calculate
the light model. Here is the diffuse. Just use N dot
L, the cosine alpha. For the specular light, we use Blinn
Phong model. This  is N dot H. The output color
from fragment shader will be weighted, you can
see, by ambient, diffuse, and specular light.
Its combination gives us the final color. So, this
is the shader we are going to use to calculate the
light model. Now we can save this file and close
it. Next in the src folder, we will add a new type
script file called light.ts. Add a new file
light.ts file. Here is the code for this file.
Here we first create an interface named light
inputs that contains parameters used for
calculating light model. This code also contains
a new function create-shape-with-light
which has four input arguments: one is the vertex
data, normal data, and light input, and the is
animation parameters. Here we set the default
light parameters if no parameters were passed,
so we have some default values for
the light parameters. Next we create
a vertex buffer and a normal buffer here.
You can see that the pipeline contains
a buffers attribute here. It is an array that contains
two elements. The first element is the vertex
data with the shader location being zero. The
second element is for the normal vector data
with the shader location being one here. The
other part of the pipeline is the same to that
we used in Project five. Next we create a uniform
data. Here we define normal matrix and a model
matrix, and view, and view-projection matrices here. For
simplicity, here we set the eye position we get
from the camera equals eye position. This means
the light vector is equal to the view vector. Here
we then create three uniform buffers: one is vertex
uniform buffer, another one is a fragment uniform
buffer, and finally it is light uniform buffer.
The vertex uniform buffer is used to store
the model matrix, vew-projection matrix, and
a normal matrix. The fragment uniform buffer is used
to store the eye position and light
position. And the light uniform buffer is used to
store the light parameters which will be used in
calculating the light model in the fragment shader
please note here, inside it is a callback
draw function, we write a model matrix
and a normal matrix inside this draw function,
because we want to use the real time model matrix
to perform various transformations. Note we
construct the normal matrix here by first inverting
this model matrix and then transposing this normal
matrix. And get the final normal matrix. This means
we do the inverse and the transpose on the original
model matrix. And finally, get normal matrix.
when we set the data to the buffer, please
note here is 64 and 128 is offset so,
we also need to use the correct offset to
write this data to the uniform buffer.
Finally, we set the vertex buffer, normal
buffer, and a uniform binding group to the
render pass. Now, we finished the coding for
the file. We can save this file and close it
Okay we completed the programming for
calculating the light model. In next project, we
will use the light model implemented here
to create a 3d cube with lighting effect.
In Project 6, I explain how to build a
simple light model in WebGPU. In this project,
I will show you how to use this light model to
add lighting effect to a 3d cube, as shown here,
You can download the source code used in this
project from this GitHub repository link.
This specific commitment
version is used for this project.
Now start Visual Studio Code and open our project
6 that we built in the last section. Here is
the code used in the project 6 as we discussed in
the last section. In order to calculate the light
model, we have to know the normal vector at each
vertex on the surface of the 3d object. Now
we need to add normal vector data to the vertex_data
of our cube. From the src folder open vertex_data.ts
file. Here for the CubeData method, we
need to add the normal vector data here
You can see that vertices on the same face
have the same normal vector. For example,
the front face all have 001.
Similarly for the right is the 100, all
the 100 and so on. Once we add the normal vector
data to this CubeData function, we need to return
the normal data here normals. We also need to
return normals. Okay now we can save this file and
close it. Next we need to make some changes to the
index.html file. From the dist folder, open
the index.html file. Now we need to replace
its content by the new code. Here we add some
input parameters here that let you test our light
model. This parameters also allow you to specify
object color, ambent, diffuse, specular
light coefficients. You can also specify
surface shininess and specular color for the
specular light computation. Now we can save this
file. Next we need to make some modifications to
the main.js file. From the src folder, open the main.js
file. Now replace its content with new code.
Since most of the code for render pipeline and
render pass hve been already included in the light
dot ts file, here the main.ts file becomes very
simple. First, we introduce the create
shape with light and the light inputs interface from
the light.ts file, and then introduce the cube data from vertex
data.ts file. Next we call the cube data method
to get the vertex data and define the default
parameter here, the light inputs, we just use
the default parameters. And also is_animation, we set
it to true. And then we call the create shape
with light function to create a 3d cube with
lighting effect. This part of the code allows the
user to recreate the cube with different lighting
effect by changing the input parameters. Now we
finished the modifications to the main.js file.
We can now save this file. Now we can run the
following command in the terminal window to bundle our
TypeScript code in production mode: npm run prod
Okay, the bundle file is created successfully.
Now we can click the Go Live link
to open Chrome Canary to view our 3d cube
with light effect. Click this link.
Here is a red cube with the lighting effect
displayed on this page. We can make some changes
to the input parameters and click the redraw button
to recreate the cube. Now, for example, we can set
the diffuse and specular coefficients to zero
here, to zero, and ambient light to one. Now click
redraw, we get a cube with ambient light only. You
can see the cube looks flat and no 3d feature.
Now let's add the diffuse light
and specular light back.
point 2. We can then change the color of the
object. For example, this red we change it to
green, 010. And also change the specular color
from white to yellow, and then click the redraw
button. You can see here the yellow you can
increase the shininess, for example, 100. You can see
the spot a little bit yellow. This is specular light.
Now, go back to animation. So by changing this parameter
you can get new lighting effect on this cube.
You can use this light model to easily create
your own 3d object by following the procedure
present here. Okay, now we have completed
project 7. The projects we discussed
so far were appled a fixed color by assigning a desired
color value to the fragment color variable
in the fragment shader. In this project,
I will explain how to use the colormap to render
3d surfaces. Surfaces play an important role in
various applications, including computer graphics
games, and 3d data visualization. In some graphics
and chart applications, we need a custom
colormap to achieve special visual effects.
In fact, the colormap is just a table or
list of colors that are organized
in some desired fashion. We can create a
custom colormap with an mx3 color matrix
with each row representing RGB values. The row index
can represent the y data of a 2d chart
or height of a 3d surface plot. For a given color
map matrix, the color data values can be linearly
scaled to the colormap. Here shows the color
strips for the colormaps that we will create
in this project. You can see that each color
map has a familiar colormap name, such as
hsv, hot, cool, and jet and so on. You can
download the source code used in this project
from this GitHub repository link. This specific
commit version is used for this project. Now
start with Visual Studio Code and open our project
7 that we just built in the last section
Here contains the source code used in the
last project. We can easily create a custom
colormap using simple mathematical formula.
Here, I will provide a several commonly
used colormaps using mx3 colormap array.
Now add a new typescript file
called colormap_data.ts file to the src
folder, s src folder, add a new file
called thecolormap_data.ts file.
And then add a new method to this file.
Here the colormap data method contains
11 different colormaps data. You can
see hsv, hot, and jet as default.
Inside this function, you can see each colormap
contains 11 RGB color arrays, each, I mean, array
here is RGB values. Here shaws the color strips generated
using this colormap dat. This is hsv, corresponding to
this color strip. So here is the jet
corresponding to this color strip. So, these color
strips are generated using colormap data. In
the colormap_data function, we assume this 11
color arrays are uniformly distributed in the range
of zero and one. For example, the color zero, the
first element represents a color at zero
location, while color 5 represents a color at
0.5, etc. However, we have to use interpolation
method to get a color at, for example, 0.55
or any other arbitrary locations. So
here, we will use an npm package called interpolate
arrays to do the color interpolation. Now in the
terminal window, we run the command: npm install,
interpolate arrays to install this package.
Now at the top of this colormap
file, we need to introduce this package
here. Here you can see again, we use a
require to introduce this package.
because it was created originally using the
old modules method. So we have to use the require
instead of import to get this package. Next,
we add a new function here called addColors
Here is addColors method to this file. This
function accepts the x argument whose value
value is in the range of minimum and maximum. This
function allows you to interpolate color for any
arbitrary x value. Inside this function, we first
get the color array by calling the colormap
data method with a colormap name as
the input. And then make sure the input
x parameter is in the range of minimum and maximum
range. Next, we normalize x to the range of
zero and one. Finally, we interpolate the color
for the X variable by calling the interp here
the color and normalize x here. This interp
comes from the interpolate_arrays package.
Now this function returns RGB array with
each component being in the range of zero and
one. So now we can save this file and
close it. Next in the src folder, rename
the light.ts file to the surface.ts
file. So we rename this file to surface.
This surface.ts file will be
used to create different surface plots.
First, we need to make small changes to the light
inputs interface. Here we can remove the color field
here, because we don't need to
specify the solid color for our object,
but we will use the colormap for the
object color. Then we add another new
field called is_two_side_lighting. Since the 3d
surfaces are usually open surfaces we need to
implement the light model for both the front and
back sides, in order to see the surface clearly,
but this parameter controls whether you
want the one-side or two-side lighting.
Next we change the function name here create
surface with the colormap. So we change
create colormap,  and then add a color data as its
input argument. Here we have normal data,
we need to add the color data. This color data means
the colormap data. Here we need to remove this color,
and add a new before the value for the is_two_side_
lighting here. Here we set the default value to one
This means the two side lighting. If zero, it is one side.
Here we create a vertex buffer, normal buffer,
we also need to create the color buffer.
Color and use the color data.
Next, here is a buffer array: the first is vertex buffer,
this is normal buffer. We also need to add
another buffer for the colormap data. So,
here we need to set the shader location to 2.
we don't need to change the other part of the code
for the pipeline. So, other part is the same as
that used in the last project. The code
for the uniform data, camera, and uniform
buffer layout is the same as that used in the
last project. So we don't need to change anything
here. But here the light parameters we need
to make some changes because the light color
we already removed. So we remove this light color,
but we need to add another parameter called is
two side lighting parameter. So we need to add
a parameter here, push the is_two_side_lighting
parameter by 0 0, 0. But we will make the parameter
consistent with the vec4 array. The other thing
we need to make a change is that we should add
the color buffer to the render pass. We have
vertex buffer and normal buffer. We also
need to add color buffer here, called color buffer here
color buffer at slot 2. Okay we finished
the modification to this file. Right now,
So we can save this file. Next we need to make
some modification to the shader code
because we want to incorporate lighting and the
colormap into the shader. So now from src folder
open the shader.wgsl file from this, open this file and
we needed to replace its content with new code.
This shader is very similar to that
used in the last project. Inside the vertex
shader, in addition to the vertex position, you
can see and normal vector we also add the color
at the location 2 to this input. Within the
vs_main function we process the colormap
and assign this colormap to the v_color.
In the fragment shader here we use the processed
colormap data as our object primary color here.
You can see v_color, this processed from
vertex shader. We use it as a primary color to
get the final color. Inside the fragment shader
the main function you can see here
the is_two_side_lighting parameter
here called the prameter zero, controls whether
the lighting is applied to one side or two sides
of our surface. We set it to one for two side
lighting, which is also default setting. For two
side lighting, you can see this for one side for
front side the diffuse we use the N dot L, specular
light we use N dot H. If two side lighting
we add another term here for the diffuse we use
minus N dot L. For the specular we use minus N dot
H. This means for the backside light, we just
reverse the normal vector to get the light for
the backside. Now we can save this file. Okay
now we've finished the programming for colormap
in this project. In the last project we discussed
the colormap model. In this project I will
explain how to use this model to build simple 3d
surfaces. Here is an example of a 3d Simple
surface created using a peaks function.
Mathematically, a surface draws a Y function on the
surface for each x and z coordinates in a region
of interest. For each x and z value pair the
simple 3d surface can have at the most one Y
value. We can define a simple surface by the y
coordinates of point above a rectangular grid.
In the x-z plane, the surface is formed by
jointing adjacent points using straight lines.
Typically, the surface is formed
using rectangular mesh grdids.
However, WebGPU only provides
triangles as the basic units to represent
any surface in 3d. In order to represent a surface
using traditional quadrilaterals, we need to write
our own functions. You can download the source
code used in this project from this GitHub
repository link. This specific commit
version is used for this project.
Now start Visual Studio Code and open project
8 that we built in the last section.
Here shows the code used in the project 8.
First we need to add a new typescript file
called surface-data.ts to the src folder, SRC
folder. Add a new file called surface-data.ts
We need to introduce vec3,  import vec3,
from gl-matrix library, and also need to import from
colormap-data.ts file, introduce
addColors function. First, let
add a utility function called normalize-point that
will be used to normalize the point to the range
of minus one and a one. So, we need to add a
function normalize function. You can see here
this function takes a 3d vec3 here
the points. x data range: X minimum, X
maximum, y minimum, y maximum, z minimum,
z maximum, and also introduce a global scale,
parameter that allows you to change the value
range for the x, y, and z coordinates. This will
be convenient for setting the default size of our
surface. This function returns the normalized 3d
point. For our simple 3d surface as shown here, this
surface can be formed by quadrilateral mesh grid
Here is one of the quadrilateral. This, as
shown here, is a unit grid cell. This
unit grid is a quadrilateral with 4 vertices
P0, p1, p2 and p3. We can divide this
quadrilateral into two triangles P0-p1-
p2, this one triangle, another triangle is
p2-p3 and P0 as shown here. We will
create a vertex data, normal vector data and
colormap data for this quadrilateral. Now,
we can add a new function called Create_Quad.
You can see here that this function takes
4 points just as shown here, point 012
and 3. It takes these 4 points as its input
arguments. It also takes vertex data range y
minimum and y maximum, as well as the colormap
name as its input parameters, because we
want to add the colormap to the y values
for our surface. Of course you can colormap
the data value in the other direction such as
x and z direction. But we usually add colormap to the y
values. here we first create
the vertex position data for the six vertices
This is point zero, point one,  point two.
This is the first triangle, this is second
triangle: point 2, point 3, and point zero. So this
is vertices for this unit cell for these two
triangles. Next, we define the normal vector for
this quadrilateral. We already discussed how to
obtain the normal vector for this quadrilateral
in the previous project. It is simply equal to
the cross product of these two diagonal lines of
this quadrilateral. Here we introduce these two
lines: first is p2-p0, p two p zero,
we call the CA, another line is  p3 and
p1, p three P one, we call it DB. Then, we get
the cross product, we call CP, these two lines,
then we normalize this CP cross product, we get
the normal vector for this quadrilateral. So, all
the vertices on this quadrilateral have the same
normal vector. Next, we add the colormap data
to vertices for this quadrilateral. You can
see the P zero p one, P two and p three, this is
the colormap data for these 4 vertices.
For P zero, you can see we add the colormap
data to it by calling the addColors function
with its y component p0[1], and using the y data
range: y minimum and Y maximum. The AddColors
function was implemented in the last project.
If you want to add colormap data to the other
direction, for example, the x direction you
should use x data range and also P zero
here inside should be zero, this is the x component.
Similarly, we add the colormap data to the
other three vertices. And finally, we add this
colormap data to these two triangles. These have
six vertices, they have a different colormap on
different vertices. Finally, create-quad function
returns vertex, normal, and color for this unit grid.
This create-quad function here only creates
the data for single unit grid. Now, we need
to create a data for the entire surface. We need
to add a new function called simple surface data.
This is a function that creates the data for entire
surface. This function takes f here this input
argument. F is a math function that describes the
3d Simple surface. We then define the data range
in the x z plane use a minimum and a maximum value
for the x and the Z. Next two input parameters
nx and nz represent the grid divisions along
the x and z directions. Here the scale is a global
scaling parameter used in the normalize
point function. The scale-y parameter is
used to control the y value height relative
to the X and Z value, that is, the scale-y parameter
here controls aspect ratio of our surface plot.
Inside this method, we first define the size
of a unit grid, you can see  dx and dz. We
then calculate the vertex position on our surface by
calling the function f. You can see we use this for
loop inside that we call the F(X,Z) function. This
describes our surface. Here we also calculate y value
range: y minimum 1, y maximum
one. Next, we reset the y value range
usng the scale-y parameter here
next, we normalize vertex position by calling
the normalized point using the value range for X
y, and Z, and also the scale. Inside this
double for loop, we first define the unit cell
P zero p one p two and p three. This is a unit
cell. Then call the Create-Quad function
to get thevertex position, normal vector, and
colormap data for this unit grid. So this
vertex normal and color for our surface.
Finally, this simple surface data function
returns the vertex data, normal data, and
colormap data. Now we finished programming
for 3d Simple surfaces in this project. In
next project, we will use this framework
to create a 3d Sinc surface with both the lighting
effect and the colormap. In the last two projects,
we discussed the colormap model and simple
3d surface construction. In this project, I will
explain how to use the colormap model
and the simple surface data function to create a
3d sinc surface as shown here. This is a pretty
sinc surface we want to create in this project.
You can download the source code used in this
project from this GitHub repository link.
This specific commit version is used for
this project. Now start with Visual Studio
Code and open our project 9 that we built
in the last section. Here is the code
used in the last project. First, we need to
make some changes to the index.html file
From the dist folder, open index dot
HTML file. Here we need to change
this h1 title to Sinc surface and then
we need to change the parameter here.
You can see here we have two_ sided_ light
parameter that controls whether we want
to apply the lighting effect to one side or two
sides of the surface. Here is a dropdown menu
for the colormap that contains 11 colormap
names we defined in the colormap-data.ts file,
so you can select different colormap for our
surface from this dropdown. Here is the scale parameter
that lets you set the default size and aspect ratio
for the sinc surface. Now we can save this file
Now let's define our sinc function. Add a new
TypeScript file called the math-func.ts file
to the src folder. Src folder, add
a new file called the math-func.ts file.
Here is a definition of the sinc
function. Here r is defined as the square root
x square plus z square. This function equals
to sign R or R if r not equal to zero. Otherwise
if it equal to zero this function is equal to one.
In fact, this function is the Fourier transform
of a rectangular function. Now we add
some code here to define this function.
You can see this function is very simple:
it takes x and z and center parameters here as
its input arguments. The center parameter here lets
you set the location of our sinc surface. Inside
this function we define r using this formula
sas shown here. So here let y, r
equals to zero, this function equal to one, otherwise
it equals to sin r  over r. This function returns a
vector three point on the sinc surface
here. Now we can save this file and close it. Next
we need to make some changes to the main.ts
file. From src folder open main.ts file and
now we need to replace the code with the new code.
Since most code for render pipeline and
render pass have been already included in the surface.ts
file. So the main.ts file here becomes very simple
Here we first introduce the simple
surface data from surface-data.ts file,
and then we introduce the sinc function from
math-func.ts file. Next from surface.ts file
we introduce create surface with Colormap
and also introduce the light inputs interface
from the surface.ts file. Next, we create a new
function called Create surface. This function takes
light inputs, is_animation, and the colormap
name, and scale, and scale-y as its input
arguments. Inside this function, we call the simple
surface data with, you see here, the sinc function
as the input argument. From this simple surface
data method, we can get the vertex position,
normal vector, and colormap data,
we then call create surface with
colormap function to create our sinc surface with
lighting and colormap effects. Here we define
the default input parameters and then we
call create surface function to create a 3d
sinc surface with default lighting
and colormap effects. This part
of the code allows the user to recreate the
sinc surface with different input parameters.
Here, this code allows the user to select the
different colormap from the dropdown menu.
Now we've finished the modification to the main.ts
file. Okay, save this file. Now we can run the
following command in the terminal window to bundle
our typescript code. Open a terminal window
and run the command: npm run prod to
bundle our TypeScript code in production mode,
Okay, the bundle file is created successfully. Now
we can click this go live link to open Chrome
Canary to view our sinc surface. Click
this link. Okay, here is our sinc surface
with default two_side_lighting and jet color
map displayed on this page. Now let's check what
happens if we use one side lighting. So we use
camera control. This is one side and we set it to zero.
You see, you see the back there is no diffusion
and specular light in the back. But the only
have very weak ambient light here,
If we set it to one you can see the back
the difference the one side and two
side. You have light on the back. Here the scale
sets the default size of surface. For example,
we change it to one, you get a smaller surface here
change it to 3, you will get a bigger surface.
So they can the default size of the
surface. We go back to 2. And here the scale y
lets you control the aspect ratio. For example,
we set it to zero, you get a taller surface.
And change it to the 0.5 you get
a shorter and fatter surface. We change it
to 0.3, so you can use this parameter
to control the aspect ratio. Next we can
change the colormap from this dropdown
menu. For example, antum, bone, cool, Cooper
gray, hot, hsv, spring, summer
and winter. So you can get different
colormap for our surface. You can see
that in WebGPU, we can easily create a
beautiful 3d surface with lighting and color
map effect. You can create your own surfaces
by simply providing your own math functions. So now
we've completed our project 10. You can use WebGPU to
create advanced graphics in your web applications.
Here are some more examples from my recently
published book "Practical WebGPU Graphics"
Here are some parametric 3d surface examples.
They all look beautiful because they have both
colormap and lighting effects as we did for the
simple 3d sinc surface in our projects. Here are
texture map examples on 3d objects. Texture plays
an important role in 3d graphics. The modern
GPUs have support for image texture built-in on
the hardware level. Texture mapping on 3d object
provides more interesting and realistic look.
These examples demonstrate that you can do texture
mapping on sphere, cylinder, and 3d surface.
You can also use multiple textures on 3d object.
You can see here: each face of our 3d Cube has a
different image texture. Here are examples of
domain coloring for functions with complex
variables. These beautiful pictures are
drawing pixel by pixel based on bitmap
render, which is a computation intensive process.
Here we perform all calculations and rendering
directly in GPU, which makes it possible for
our real time animation here. This is impossible
in CPU. These are 3d fratal examples. They provide
more structures than 2d fractals. Again, this
nice pictures can be only create in GPU. In CPU,
it is too slow and impossible to have this
real time animation. Here are some example for
large particle systems. This is a compute
boids and we try to simulate the flocking
behavior of birds. This picture shows
particle kinematics with collision to the wall.
This shows three mass centers that
attract particles. Here we use Compute shader
to perform physics related computations and update
the positions and velocities on each frame. This
is only possible in GPU for simulating this large
particle system in real time. If you want to learn
how to create these pictures and particle
systems, please visit my website at Dr. Xu
dotnet.com and my YouTube channel at Practical
Programming with Dr. Xu. Thank you for watching